Iran has condemned the European Union
for imposing new sanctions over its
response to anti-government protests the
EU announced measures targeting Iran's
State broadcaster its Army Chief
revolutionary guards commanders and an
Iranian cleric protests have swept Iran
since the death on September the 16th of
a young Iranian Kurdish woman in police
custody now courts in Iran have
sentenced 11 people to death in
connection with the ensuing protests the
first two people were executed in the
past week more than eighteen thousand
Iranians have been arrested including
close members of the family of hayatoli
ayatollahi now his niece is one of the
Supreme leaders sharpest critics
[Music]
it's difficult to get a full picture of
life in Iran right now but when a video
is published the eyes of the world are
on it
not since the Islamic revolution have
the Iranian people made their voices
heard so loud and clearly and at such
great risk to their lives
honest critics the Prem leaders own nice
has spoken out harshly against her uncle
and called on foreign governments to cut
all ties with Tehran is a portrait
that cannot remember oh free people be
with us and support us though that your
government stops supporting this
murderous and child-killing regime
dangerous words in the Islamic Republic
where she was arrested for
eign is currently in jail and Tehran
where according to her lawyer she'll
spend the next three years
opposition to the Supreme Leader runs in
the family
faridee muradhani's late father was a
prominent critic of the Iranian regime
her brother is an activist living in
Exile in France
this branch of the ayatoya's family
doesn't want anything to do with his
Hardline religious policies or his
Crackdown on descent
[Music]
Khan has been going on for three months
and the rage on the streets has only
increased
in this video people in Tehran can be
heard chanting I'll kill whoever killed
my brother and death to the dictator
after a man was executed for his role in
the protests
it's tiny glimpses into Iranian life
like this one that show that the
ultimate deterrent isn't enough to
silence the Iranian people
or the ayatollah's own family
now as we just heard the niece of Iran's
supreme leader is one of his harshest
critics and so is her brother activist
Mahmoud Murad khani has lived in Paris
for more than 20 years he was the one
who published her video message to the
world maradkani sat down for an
exclusive interview with DW's Farsi
department and he told us what makes
these last three months of protests so
important
that what this regime said about the
former regime was a lie
they have told many lies and now they
are lying about their daily routines
about the economy
about everything
and of course about political issues
they kill people in the street
and then they say those people had a
stroke and died
all right I believe that we can now
speak to Hadi gami he is the founder of
the center for human rights in Iran and
he is joining us now from New York
welcome to DW we heard the ayatollah's
own nephew there saying that the people
of Iran are no longer afraid of the
regime would you say that that is true
um absolutely and I think that is the
message that the International Community
needs to hear that this movement this
protests are absolutely different than
previous ones of course they are related
but they have entered a new stage and we
need to really have new policies in this
regard we know that already two people
have faced the death penalty uh in the
last week is that something that do you
think will deter people from taking to
the streets and continuing this protest
movement
well they're trying they're very much
trying that involve the ultimate goals
of this execution but uh let's also note
that over 480 people already been killed
on the streets in front of this
protesting population
including 60 children
and it may on short term for a day or
two cause a lot of intimidation but uh I
think the waiver protest will come
rolling back and I just want to
emphasize that particularly European
Union needs to be prepared to have
different policies than just imposing
sanctions I you mentioned the children
who have been caught up in this now we
are hearing that children are among
those who've been arrested who are being
held as political prisoners what else
can you tell us about that
indeed we know there are uh we're not
sure of the total number but we know
that there are at least over 18 000
people in general been detained over
three months and around 10 000 of them
remaining in prison and hundreds of them
are children under the age of 18. and
there's a lot of concern for them I want
to go back also to what you were saying
about the European Union do you think
that the new sanctions imposed on the
Islamic Republic by the EU will help and
does the regime in Tehran actually even
care about its image on the world stage
exactly look this sanctions are
necessary about not sufficient they
should continue as needed but they
cannot become the core of the policy
what we really need now is a very strong
message that is
tangible to Iranian government and I
highly recommend that the European Union
as well as other countries with
ambassadors in Iran should be pulling
out their ambassadors intend them
together
uh back to their capital and demand the
moratorium immediate moratorium on
capital punishment uh before uh the
ambassadors go back and to constantly
call on Iranian ambassadors in Europe
daily to foreign Ministries and register
uh protests and concerns and furthermore
there should be a very strong will to
take the case of Iran selling drones to
Russia in violation of Security Council
resolution to the security Council and
together with the violence against women
and children these are all causes that
should be discussed by the security
Council
a founder and executive director of the
center for human rights in Iran thank
you so much for taking the time to speak
with us
thank you for that